[Música]
en la inmensidad del universo los seres
humanos somos puntos
que se unen se distancian como se
conglomeran otros se alejan pero cuando
se acercan demasiado es en ese momento
cuando entre estos dos puntos cupido
lanza una flecha hacia el otro punto y
en una línea recta podemos exclamar
estoy enamorada
como es posible que haya yo he podido
vivir sin esto qué barbaridad
el enamoramiento se da ocurre llega a
nuestras vidas y la mayor parte de las
veces es totalmente inesperado
este es el sentimiento al que le
llamamos amor
cuántas veces al consultorio llegan
parejas que por fin dicen rocío ahora sí
he encontrado a mi media naranja
ahora sí me siento llena ahora sí estoy
completo como si pudiéramos andar por la
calle y sin la presencia del otro sólo
fuéramos un solo pie una sola pierna un
solo brazo un solo ojo y por supuesto la
mitad del cerebro
sin embargo qué pasa meses después o
años llegan ya casados ya veces hasta
con hijos y entonces la fantasía de ese
amor se acabó
qué pasó qué pasó con el amor
recuerdo a maría diciendo rocío te
acuerdas era tan cuidadoso conmigo todo
el día que estarme besando que dispara
encima de mí
me dejaba mi abrazado me decía que amaba
pero hoy ni siquiera me mira
se me hacía tan divertido
y hoy odio que sea el alma de la fiesta
y yo le digo maría por favor no era eso
lo que más te gustaba
los puntos que se unen entre una línea y
otra que en un principio se unieron en
una línea directa al corazón
de repente se encuentran con otros
puntos en este vasto universo y empiezan
a formar triángulos cuadrángulos
hexágonos o hasta pentágonos y este
momento es en que en el amor romántico
entre dos se ve amenazado por algo que
solemos llamar infidelidad
esta es una de las trampas más grandes
de la relación de pareja nosotros
crecimos con la idea y la historia de
que nos íbamos a casar tener muchos
hijos y por supuesto ser muy felices
pero además vivir eternamente con esta
pareja hasta que la muerte nos separe
pero
que de aquellos que afirman que los
hijos son el enemigo número uno de la
pareja
otras de las trampas es pensar que
estaremos tremendamente enamorados todo
el tiempo y deseando esa persona que
elegimos para siempre sin embargo nadie
nadie nos dice que si bien podemos
comprometer nuestro espacio de pareja un
proyecto familiar un proyecto económico
no podemos comprometer el deseo hacia
otra persona
este si acaso se podría administrar si
lo sabemos hacer
esto podemos decidir simplemente actuar
aunque sintamos deseo por otro o no
cuántas veces nos hemos preguntado qué
hacer frente a esa sensación seductora
por otra persona y estoy hablando de
seducción desde desde un lugar diferente
ese momento en el que lo único que
quiero es hablar con esa persona
mantener en el pensamiento esa persona
querer ir y correr y buscar
aunque sea un instante
cuidado por lo general huele a peligro
porque casi nadie lo sabe
tendemos a buscar en el amor seguridad
y este en cambio necesita libertad e
incertidumbre a mayor certeza en la
relación disminuye el deseo en la pareja
por ejemplo si ha iniciado un coche
convertible toda mi vida un coche rojo
convertibles para salir y como dicen por
ahí [ __ ] ar
en el momento en que lo tengo
se acaba el deseo porque porque ya lo
puso yo
recuerdo a louis pidiéndole a patti que
le diera todas las claves de todas sus
computadoras de su teléfono del snap del
chat de todo esto
para ti se había negado fuertemente y
louis seguía insistiendo insistiendo
insistiendo y él lo que quería era
seguridad disfrazada de amor su relación
era muy dinámica por supuesto muy
energética pero que creen después de
algún tiempo para ti accedió
se las dio y este fue el principio del
fin el flechazo se acabó y muy pronto la
monotonía y la cotidianidad lo
sobrepasaron
que había sucedido
el hecho de que el deseo no se
comprometa y no sea exclusivo no
significa que no podamos tener una
pareja que sea única
exclusivas y excepcional para el otro
hay que aceptar y construir este nuevo
pacto de las relaciones amorosas que
vienen acompañadas de estas geometrías
que son diferentes que van más allá de
esta línea recta al corazón
hoy curiosamente los jóvenes lo que
están haciendo es queriendo tener
relaciones más tradicionales
porque probablemente porque sienten que
su mundo
está siendo muy incierto y los adultos
estamos tratando de tener relaciones
mucho más amorfas que no vivimos en
nuestra juventud
en los inicios del siglo 21 esta manera
de mirar al mundo se ha transformado ya
no hablamos de líneas rectas ahora
hablamos de espirales
de círculos
y la pareja asimismo se está
transformando y está pareciendo como
caótica
y en constante transformación
empecemos a generar nuevas maneras de
relacionarnos amorosamente ya no somos
una media naranja ya no somos uno mismo
el amor se ha convertido en un prisma de
múltiples facetas como el poliamor y
relaciones a distancia
relaciones en donde se dan en las redes
sociales o en la realidad virtual oa
través de la inteligencia artificial
parejas que aunque casadas han decidido
vivir en el mismo espacio pero ya no
teniendo relaciones sexuales
compartiendo hijos compartiendo la casa
compartiendo el espacio pero si era una
vida marital hoy es muy común
encontrarnos con parejas y matrimonios
que tienen el mismo género y en toda la
gama del conjunto lgv de cv con
diferentes edades sabores y colores
como dejar de ser un solo punto en esta
línea
como aprender a ser parte de este prisma
a ser una de esas aristas como
relacionarnos a través de la
inteligencia artificial o debiera decir
en la inteligencia artificial
porque me estoy acordando de la película
de here de joaquin phoenix se acuerdan
aquella película en la que él termine
enamorado de esa madre
es como si cualquiera de nosotros
estuviéramos enamorados decir cualquier
parecido con la realidad es pura
coincidencia
extendamos este abanico de posibilidades
alejémonos de esta geometría euclidiana
de un solo plano echemos de un vistazo a
las nuevas formas de las relaciones de
pareja a las nuevas geometrías amorosas
reconozcamos esta multiplicidad
cambiante o como diría paul mann
en el amor líquido un amor que se
desvanece entre los dedos
hace algún tiempo recuerdo cuando ruth
llegó a mi espacio conversacional y
venir a ellas con una laptop entrando en
la puerta y dijo ya llegué yo pensé que
me lo estaba diciendo a mí pues no entro
se sentó conectó su laptop y me dijo
rocío volteo la laptop
rocío venimos a terapia de pareja te
presento ha ayudado
y yo
ok
joao se encontraba en brasil
igualmente tengo presente el día que
mike llegó con tres personas más
a mi espacio conversacional y me dijo
venimos a que nos ayudes a comunicarnos
de una mejor manera ya llevarnos mejor
porque los celos están terribles
habían decidido practicar el poliamor
pero se les estaba dificultando
enormemente claro los polis amorosos son
aquellos que deciden amar a más de una
persona y les es posible aunque muchas
personas lo hacen nada más que en este
caso todos lo saben lo que sucede en las
relaciones hoy y en el futuro
su forma podría ser como una molécula
una molécula que se construye de varios
elementos que constantemente se están
moviendo
o del amor líquido en donde una gotita
se junta con otra y se sabe así
simplemente ocurre y se da
me quedo pensando que hace que viviendo
en un mundo globalizado como el que
estamos viviendo con tan pocas certezas
sigamos creyendo en el amor romántico
que se practicó en el siglo 19
qué es lo que hace que nos perdemos a un
ideal o una fantasía que además hoy no
está funcionando
amar a alguien porque lo necesitas no es
amar
es ser dependiente dicen aquellos que
dicen que saben
seamos pocos fundamentalistas
atrevámonos a crear inventemos nuevas
matices comencemos a entender las nuevas
geometrías amorosas en nuestras vidas
atrevámonos a crear relaciones en las
que queremos estar no en las que tenemos
que estar
me quedo pensando y mientras hablaba con
ustedes
de un momento para mi mágico
y vas caminando con mi sobrina
y me dijo
día
todo está cambiando
el mundo la vida yo tú todos
y en ese momento la interrumpí
y le dije
gime sí
todo está cambiando hasta el amor
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]